[Music]
audiences aren't the only ones who get
the willies from borer movies for some
actors the process of starring in a film
full of jump scares and weapon wielding
maniacs can leave some long lasting
emotional marks in the case of these
scary movie stars being a part of a
fright flick took a toll on their
psyches during and sometimes even after
production the chestburster
the chest bursting scene from alien
ranks among the most iconic moments in
all of sci-fi film history and there's
no doubt that it worked so well because
the cast really didn't know what was
about to happen and were genuinely
shocked and terrified by it director
Ridley Scott explained this decision for
letting the creatures cruel reveal
happen in real time during the shoots by
telling Empire magazine the reactions
were going to be the most difficult
thing if an actor is just acting
terrified you can't get the genuine look
of raw animal fear his approach to
eliciting sincere scares worked as
Veronica Cartwright later remember you
see this thing start to come out so we
all get sucked in we lean forward to
check it out all of a sudden that comes
out I tell you none of us expected it it
came out and twisted round Cartwright
reportedly passed out as a result of the
scene and still talks about how upset it
made her to this day the clause the
real-life ghost hunting history of Ed
and Lorraine Warren is freaky enough to
put anyone on edge but actress bereft
Farmiga knew very little of her
character's real-life counterpart before
signing on for the conjuring and
receiving her first paranormal encounter
as a welcome gift while she was doing
research on Warren's work she had a
brush with the beyond after she hung up
the phone with director James Wan cinema
blend reported her saying I opened the
computer screen and there were three
digital claw marks from the upper right
diagonal to the lower left it wasn't
enough to steer her away from the movie
but the haunting experience did follow
her through to the film's end the day
after she finished shooting the first
film and returned to her home in New
York she woke up to find something even
scarier three claw mark bruises on her
thigh even though she chose not to give
in to the fear of the moment she said
she had to build up an emotional armor
to deal with what she experienced with
those series of scratch marks
the curtain when it comes to the horror
genre Patrick Wilson is something of a
scream King the actors filmography is
filled with freaky fare but it was the
second conjuring film that freaked the
actor out the most according to him
there was a pretty trippy moment during
production involving a certain haunting
that led the crew to bring in a priest
to bless the set
he told Metro it was a huge curtain that
went from the floor to the ceiling which
was sort of waving violently and there
was no door open or fan on no nothing
you didn't even hear any air but you
watched these curtains sort of violently
going
Wilson considers himself a skeptic but
this moment may have gotten the better
of him because he's admitted to
believing his own house might be haunted
now he told the independent I've heard
people on two different occasions say
they've heard kids laughter in the
middle of the night in my house perhaps
he should do a few more comedies in
between haunted house picks the visitor
James Brolin was initially unsure about
the 1979 adaptation of Jay Anson's true
story inspired novel The Amityville
Horror realize what I was getting into
he gave the book a look and got so
frightened by what happened to him mid
read that he accepted the gig right then
and there
Brolin explained to the AV Club I would
hang my pants on the door of the bedroom
and all of a sudden the pants fell off
the door and onto the floor I was in a
scary part of this book and so it
surprised me that I started laughing
after I recovered and said I've got to
do this movie and he wasn't the only
Amityville alum to succumb to
superstition associated with the series
the 2005 remake was also the site of
some freakish coincidences such as a
fisherman's body washing up on the set
shore as filming geared up to begin Ryan
Reynolds told movie web a lot of the
crew were waking up at 3:15 in the
morning which was when all these
atrocities in the house took place each
time I think it was a subconscious thing
you read the script and suddenly pop
awake at 3:15 in the morning even if
it's just a coincidence it's still
creepy the box he might be playing a
savage bat slinging brute of the zombie
apocalypse in The Walking Dead but
Jeffrey Dean Morgan got pretty worked up
over his time on the
of the possession he admitted to being
so freaked out by the real history of
the Dybbuk box that they made sure not
to take it lightly during filming he
told I Oh 9 there are some weird
goings-on on set
lots of lightbulbs exploding just
overall kind of creepiness don't mock
the box was sort of the mantra that we
lived by while we were filming this he
purposefully steered clear of the real
box that inspired the film saying
somebody wanted to bring the box to the
set the real box I was adamantly against
it if you go and look at what has
happened to people that have had contact
with an actual Dybbuk box it's not good
stuff why risk that why indeed the clown
capturing the essence of Pennywise the
clown for the cinematic adaptation of
Stephen King's it would be no easy feat
for anyone not only was there a prior
portrayal by Tim Curry to live up to but
unlike most villains there are no human
or redeeming qualities to latch on to to
make an actor feel better about playing
it understandably for Bill skarsgård the
process of suiting up as the child
Slayer was no picnic the actor has said
that the process of spending time with
this character was like a destructive
relationship that he was relieved to end
when his part rap even putting away
penny wises costume wasn't enough to
keep the bad vibe to fade out he told
Entertainment Weekly I was home done
with the movie and I started having very
strange and vivid
Pennywise dreams every night he came and
visited it was in the shape of either me
dealing with him sort of penny wise as a
separate entity of me and then also me
as penny wise and circumstances that I
didn't appreciate like I'm Benny wise
and I'm really upset that I'm out in
public and people are looking at sounds
awful but it couldn't have been too bad
skarsgård signed on to reprise his role
for its chapter 2 thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]
[Applause]